all right sorry Adrian gotta jump cause
viewers to a press conference being
given now by the Chinese national health
commission let's listen in to what
they're saying well just without break
we have been able to identify the
passenger as a new type Crona by virus
and afterwards we have formulated
technical plans including case
prevention prevention control images
committee i'm tami a logical observation
we have also conducted surgical
observation and provides the medical
cases to the medical agencies we have
enhanced the in capability of the timely
infectious disease capabilities you have
guided the ohan to provide the
prevention measures who have taken this
as top priority in proper priority I've
set up a 8 to working group we have also
closed relative markers in speedy manner
tighten control the legal braiding and
transportation trading and the
consumption of wildlife and wild animals
we have closed on a temporary basis
airports train stations and other
channels from Wuhan to prevent the
spread of virus we have also coordinated
the mobilization for Central Medical
Reserve to distribute relevant materials
to Han and we have transported prepare
Parata suit masks gloves and goggles to
Han in central government has earmarked
to 1 billion yuan for funds in such a
budget for just about the prevention and
treating in Hubei Province have several
teams of 900 doctors in her bio Han and
some doctors are ready for departure in
a military also sent 450 military
doctors and a matter of workers we have
also eight teams I'd reserve teams of
over 1000 people - ready for departure
and thirdly we have stress in the
nationwide decision prevention control a
total of 30 provinces
have initiated level 1 response to
public emergencies and formulated
community based plans for prevention
control we have introduced great based
copy star management
tracked the house conditions of people
leaving Wuhan and also people that have
travel to harm we have promoted good
practices of preaching and herb a in
professional control of the disease we
have provided free ticket to can return
services for air flight strings and also
on expressways and waterways disbanded
to groups and imposed control on
large-scale activities to reduce the
concentration of personnel we have also
issued public prevention and precaution
guides in six aspects and imposed strict
measures and ventilation temporary
temperature screening and a
sterilization of the key spots and a
closed transportation vehicles force
efforts to treat patient we have
formulated element 8 treatment plans
published the list of designated
hospitals and fever clinics about at
country level we have combined
traditional Chinese medicine and best
emerging and introduced individualized
treatment plans for patients in critical
conditions we have also implemented not
just ensure that the treatment phase
will be subsidized for the patients to
make sure that no patients will need to
worry about medical expenses fifth
intensifying scientific research who
have set up a nationwide group to seek
breakthrough in passage in tracing
critical infection treatment virus
research and traditional Chinese
medicine prevention six public education
every day at eight o'clock
national health condition will publish
national data of infection
and made enough for midnight of previous
table and provide interpretations of the
relevant policy measures then spread the
knowledge of knowledge of disease
prevention to the public servants to in
deepens cooperation we have many
information about disease prevention to
the whu-oh who have shared for genomic
sequence of the virus can strings and
the director-general of the world's
house organization have showed showed
the appreciation to the government to
demonstrate to the Chinese leadership in
global house we have have gathered
expert in Wuhan Hong Kong and Macau to
work together and after evaluation this
established will be established is not a
public house emergency of international
concern is not such concern we believe
that week-long Spring Festival occasion
it's the best window for isolation and a
sterile sterilizers underground skill
and critical period for preventing the
spread the disease of outside Wu Han
going forward under the leadership of
such leading group and prevention and
control will provide guidance and target
measures to understand the trends in the
work according to law and force way
fifth we will be will be working in
Hogan Han Han and Hunan province to
enforce matches according to law to make
sure that people are close contact will
be reduced at a concentration level and
to working together to under temporary
and terminal fashion to make the disease
control disease in to reduce and next
next will be strengthening our planning
and certainly prevent wrestling prevent
prevention control and all personnel
travel to other parts of part of Wuhan
in the last 15 ting days will be good
for
the communities no patients will be left
to worry about medical expenses some of
the comments being made there by ma sha
way the director of the Chinese national
health Commission outlining several
points in several steps which the
government is taking to try and get a
handle on the corona virus which is
emerged from Wuhan region let's go over
now to Scott Heidler he's in Beijing
start listening in to this very clear
message to underline I guess all of this
is that the government is aware and is
in control of what's happening
absolutely it's kind of a list going
down a list of what they have done and
what they need to do and as you
highlighted there send me one of the
things is that you know people are
concerned about what kind of care
they're going to be getting and they're
saying that the government is saying
that no expenses will be paid by any of
the civilians the citizens who are
impacted by this virus one thing
insisting as they click down you know
something that that was emphasized and
that is the resources that have gone
down to Wuhan and to the affected areas
that they are doing as much as they
possibly can because there has been a
lot of criticism on social media
particularly in Wuhan because of lack of
medical staff lack of supplies that are
needed in those areas and as we heard
they have sent down some military medics
some military personnel and other
civilian medical personnel down there
but from what we're hearing there still
is a lack of staff and a lack of
supplies one thing that's interesting
that they're trying to do to to combat
that there are two hospitals being built
right now for the corona virus we know
that one they started a couple of days
ago they say that should be done in a
couple of days the second one they're
saying is probably to take another
couple of weeks they're looking at
possibly two thousand-plus beds again
this is specifically to deal with this
corona virus situation now this is
something we saw 17 years ago during the
SARS outbreak there was a hospital built
very hastily just outside here in
Beijing but again it's just you know
this is
kind of a list the laundry list if you
will kind of a reassurance of what the
government is doing for this coronavirus
you know it was interesting she's been
paying the president's coming out
yesterday saying that this is a great
situation and they're dealing with it
and they're communicating again that's
something they said in this press
conference the the Ministry of Health
National Health that they're working
with WHL they're sharing information
with w-h-o because that's something
they're very much criticized about
seventeen years ago all right
thanks Scott hi blur there and now we're
going to speak to Ethan Brown he's in
Hong Kong outside a theme park that's
been shot down clearly despite or
perhaps because of all the containment
measures it's really sucking the life
out of what would usually be some lively
New Year's celebration days absolutely
Sammy I mean in what is another body
blow to Hong Kong's tourism industry
already reeling from you know months of
protests Ocean Park one of the most
popular tourist attractions in Hong Kong
has announced that it's going to be
closed until further notice the same
goes for the Disney theme park on Lantau
Island near here that's also going to
close until further notice both places
extremely popular with tourists from the
mainland and as I say it's another nail
in the coffin of Hong Kong's ailing
economy tourism arrivals here in Hong
Kong have dropped by more than 50
percent in the past six months and of
course tourism is the lifeblood of the
Hong Kong economy but these places are
going to remain shut until further
notice because the authorities here are
anxious to try to further contain the
spread of this virus so far there are
five confirmed infections here in Hong
Kong but also several hundred suspected
cases now of course this all has echoes
of the SARS virus seventeen years ago
almost 300 people died then so what
lessons if any have been learned since
that time I've been finding out
all right thanks so much Adrian Brown
there